let's take a drink all of us okay thank
you for the kind invitation so talk
about my research that I've been doing
with the company called recycling
technologies basically trying to deal
with all the waste plastic that we have
around not just in the UK but in Europe
and in the world so how much do we like
plastics okay well since 1950s you can
see the increase in the amount of
plastics has been used day on day year
on year and the people interested around
about 1975 - strike bit of a economic
recession and similarly 2009 you can see
the dips where the world consumption
plastic went down which is a bit of a
godsend for us if you're looking from my
point of view we don't want these
plastics obviously from a business point
of view we want them but from an
environmental point of view we don't so
all the plastics that we use generally
end up in something it looks like this
this is something you're probably not
familiar with but if you take your green
bin and shake it across your garden you
may have something looks like this so
you get a lot of mix plastics okay the
problem here is the mixed nests of this
plastic so your recycling plant will do
with a certain amount of this plastic it
deals with two types of plastics so
basically your your coke bottle and your
water bottles all your milk bottle tend
to get recycled and reused into
something else so we're left with lots
and lots of other plastic that we don't
know what to do with so where does our
plastic come from where comes from lots
and lots of industries so construction
packaging tend to be one of the largest
sectors in all this equates to forty six
point four million tonnes of plastic
waste or plastic that is generated in
the EU and Switzerland and Norway but
cases a 27 countries these are the two
countries so what happens next we send
twenty four point seven million tonnes
of this plastic to a recycling plant
which is great okay you're already
seeing there's a bit of a deficit there
to start with okay so when it goes to a
recycling plant
fourteen point three million tons of
that plastic waste I said that is in
your bin not all of it gets recycled
only fourteen point three million turns
gets recycled of that plastic another
ten point four million tons disappears
somewhere goes to landfill so let's just
add up all the maths we also have
another twenty 1.7 million tons the
difference between here okay it's there
so this equates to basically 69% of
plastic that's in the wrong place that
we need to do something with okay weird
out with that our recycling here we can
recycle I reuse turn it into useful
products again or we can turn it into
energy in some countries follow this
route more than other countries so what
does this all mean okay so basically we
have about 32 million tons of plastic
waste that we can do something with if
we were to convert this all into energy
okay if we took basically crack all the
bonds and I come back to them at minute
what actually means if we took crack all
the bonds we could generate 84 gigawatt
hours of electricity which if you look
at the the an energy consumption for the
UK this would basically power all the
energy required for the Greater London
and the southeast and more just from all
this waste okay but obviously we need a
technology to be able to do this so it's
a little bit further just expand on this
the mount that's recycled this is 50 to
7.9 percent of the material gets
recycled so this is 50 to 7.9 percent of
the 24 million tonnes that gets into our
recycle lines let's look at their
countries across Europe and some do it
better than others okay so I've
highlighted the UK we tend to follow
people rather than set precedents in
this area but we recycle around about 22
percent of our material about 9% we
actually burn as a fuel because it's
very high calorific calorific value our
polymers we can burn them as a fuel
so we recycle about 31 percent so we're
below the EU average whereas Germany
this is largely from a precedent set
from the country they don't want to put
any any waste to landfill
actually recycle similar amounts of the
UK about 30% but they essentially burn
the rest of the fuel they burn it in
very very large powerplant generation
facilities where they usually heat water
and raise steam then put it through a
turbine that in its own right has losses
so you start to lose and the energy that
you could potentially use they're also
very very expensive and I said
especially in Germany they have to have
support from the government to make
these things work okay because the
return from investment is very very low
on this they usually run as a loss
problem with these when you burn the
plastics they also create a lot of heat
so what do you do with the heat you need
to do something with it so the idea
would be to have your great big power
plant and to have it next to a housing
estate so houses could actually use the
heat to heat their homes which they do
but who wants a great big dirty
recycling plant in the middle of your
housing estate so we need to think a
little bit more smartly how we actually
can tackle this so people can still use
these plastics and get the energy from
them but don't have to have all the side
effects all the things we don't want
about it so what we suggest is a bit of
a scheme that's ok is our our system is
a little bit smaller than these very
very large power generation plants and
they can fit within existing recycling
facilities and manufacturing facilities
so basically we have a treatment process
so we can this is one of our small units
7,000 tonnes per annum comes in we treat
it to get it into a particle size that
we want that we can feed into our
special unit here though this is where
all the science goes on so this is the
research that I've been doing at
Birmingham it's basically making this
work okay and I'll come back to that in
a minute
the energy that comes out will have
obviously a calorific value which we can
put through a big engine essentially we
put it through a great big diesel engine
or very similar to a ship engine and we
can create energy from this good thing
about this because they're small because
we can fit them into localized
it is we don't have to transport lots
and lots of plaques or plastics to one
location site so we're cutting down on
emissions from transportation as well
so let's look at the values let's look
at the business case around this we sell
these units for about two and half a
million but if you look at how much
you're actually saving okay at the
moment because it goes to landfill a lot
of the companies that actually recycle
do not want to put these materials into
landfill because they have to pay a
landfill tax so a lot of companies are
actually storing these materials in
warehouses at the moment until the
landfill tax or something comes along
that can deal with it so you're going to
save between eighteen hundred pounds per
ton depending only on the UK so if
you're processing thousand seven
thousand tons per annum you can save
five hundred sixty thousand pounds
straight away okay because you put it
through an engine and creating 2.7
megawatts of electricity the end of it
which is enough to power five thousand
homes in the UK typically you can also
sell this electricity to the grid so
you're going to generate just over a
million pounds in the electricity
because you also produce some heat as
well we can sell the heat or Sita to the
local facilities because obviously we'll
generate heat we can sell it to the
Industrial Estate in maybe to some
houses but because it's not this great
big dirty power plant it's a smaller
unit people are generally more
acceptable to its use so you can also
save on heating costs about three
hundred eighty thousand pounds a year so
it all stacks up so over a about 15
months you can get a return on your
investment quite quickly so this all
sounds great doesn't it you think great
I want one of these and get my checkbook
out so everyone but most must want one
of these yeah that was our belief and
probably your belief so we can build
enough machines we can dot them around
the globe and we can save the world from
drowning in this waste plastic that we
don't know what to do with which has a
very very good use however I touched on
this to start this is where the pig's
ear comes in this waste is heterogeneous
it contains lots and lots of different
plastics and these plastics have
different calorific values so if you're
trying to produce
an output that has a steady calorific
value to go into your engine so your
engine runs it a constant rate it
doesn't really happen unless we do
something with the technology okay so
this is where it all falls down but we
have answers to it what your energy
buyer doesn't want is variability and
this is a big thing that you see with
renewables is the variability in power
keeping a a sustained power source all
the time so when the Sun doesn't shine
can you store the energy for example as
we saw you can because your waste also
has lots of other chemicals in it it's
not just these polymeric materials which
are if you think back to your your
organic chemistry at school carbon and
hydrogen
lots of repeat units make these polymer
chains okay but there's lots of other
things within them especially in glues
for example you get silicones you get
sulfurs you get chlorines especially in
polyvinyl chloride so all these have to
be treated so we have a filter section
here because we don't if we let fluorine
bill don't we can get hydrochloric acid
being formed which will make our
reactors fall apart or our system fall
apart but more importantly things like
silicon can react with oxygen in the
engine it makes and you obviously don't
want sound in your engine so there's
lots of challenges that we've had to
address during this research we believe
we're a position now where we can
actually go forward with this so in
answer to the question can you make a
silk person with a pig's ear we believe
you can by some some clever technology
and this is just in brief we have a very
dynamic system so it can react very very
quickly so our reactor can respond to
the demands of our engine so we can get
this constant supply of fuel to our
engine in terms of its calorific value
so just talk you through the graph these
are just carbon units so this is methane
ch4 natural gas larger component actual
gas from anything that we can we can
burn it has a very high calorific value
obviously to crack our long polymer
chains down to these units requires a
lot of energy so we like to stop out is
something we're near the Green Line
about our c6 associ carbons in it in a
change so very similar to it's a benzene
for example that you find in petrol so
it burns quite nicely so during our
first cracking process so when we stop
to break all the chains if we end up
with something on this diagram centers
around c11 to make our process
sustainable so we get in a higher
calorific content rather than going down
to the calorific content here about 44
we want it up at 45 so it's constant we
would crack the chains further in the
process to get a constant supply of fuel
going in to our engine okay so in
summary we believe now we have the
technology that we don't have to deal
with all this waste plastic anymore
there are the technologies out there
that we can find ways to to get round
storing plastic it has a high calorific
value it is a very good fuel if the
process is there and we believe it is
and we don't have to spend a vast a lot
fast expensive money to do this anymore
it doesn't have to be located in very
very large buildings and because of this
it can be applied in lots of industries
that have a waste that need to be deal
that doesn't need to be dealt with so
just gonna throw this question out to
you they a lot of governments especially
in the UK are on about reuse and recycle
ie turn something useful your bottle
into another bottle they don't always
look at the obvious solution basically
turning your bottle into energy so we've
done some calculations and we're saying
for each kilogram of plastic as diverter
going to landfill we basically saved one
kilogram of natural gas being burnt okay
so we're basically reducing the amount
of carbon that people are putting into
the atmosphere this is based on these
figures and if you can see them so we
say that one kilogram of plastic is has
a general calorific value of 31 mega
joules per kilogram so relatively high
energy content similar to coal and our
process works at 65 percent efficiency
so that's about 20 mega joules of energy
whereas gas as a higher calorific value
but the processes that actually burn gas
are very in
efficient down to about 39% and the
comparative figures equates about 20
mega joules of electricity as well so
this is where my analogy comes from okay
so thank you very much for your
attention thank you very much Gary now
any questions and did everyone remember
their a-level chemistry of a consignment
that comes into your plant how much
plastic is recycled and used for
something else and how much is turned
into energy ie burnt okay well we say
comes into our plant our plant won't
exist through 2040 we just take the
first order for the first plant so our
our aim would be to try and get hold of
all that waste material that is going to
go to landfill we wouldn't touch the the
material that helped or a as a current
use economically that can be then reused
or Rita re-engineered into a another
milk bottle or another coca-cola bottle
so you wouldn't touch that
so we'll be aiming for the 69% of
material in the UK obviously that was
across Europe in the UK it's about
nearly two and a half million tonnes of
plastic waste that we can thank you
thanks very much Chris Hawking from the
Deutsche Bank I'm just trying to work
out if dealing with all the different
types of plastics coming into the into
the into the unit is so difficult why
not speak with coca-cola and get a mate
get them to make all their bottles that
are the same material they're made out
of that material because it has a
certain quality that they're looking for
they're looking for opaqueness in their
bottles whereas milk producers of what
was going down the route that you don't
have to see your milk so they do it for
a marketing point that people want to
see their drink and I do not research
into biodegradable cling film the
problem cling film moments not
biodegradable but trying to make that
biodegrade was very very difficult
because it has very unique properties
and what will we end up with all the
time is something that's quite opaque
so you take it to the consumer and they
want to so when you buy your packet
tomatoes you don't want it's cloudy
opaqueness on your tomatoes you want to
be able to see your product so this is
the the challenge that we face of it's
the public perception of what are
products that should look like on the
shelf and if you change that they will
go somewhere else they'll go to
competitors so I think we're we're stuck
with how coca-cola were to market their
products the key manufacturers are they
have a sympathetic empathetic wanting to
close that loop or or is it truly the
consumer that is driving that that
agenda your you'll find that
supermarkets have agendas for their
suppliers their supplies needs to be
that need to tick green boxes
essentially so if you have a supplier
that doesn't have certain legislations
in place or acts to act environmentally
and how they produce their goods then
they can essentially go elsewhere to
find another supplier that does tick
this box so I suppose to supermarkets
now a very very keen to actually tick
these boxes so we can they can go back
and say all the energy that's been you
know all the materials that's been used
in a process or when a product actually
gets used for something at the end
rather than just lying stagnant in a
warehouse or in the ground from the
first question really which is whether
in a clever way you don't create resolve
or an environmental problem and create
another and I'm then thinking
particularly about some natural gas and
the fact that it is captured when when
you make the bottles report there's a
feedstock
and then of course you're proposing that
you would release it back into the
atmosphere which has been one of the big
concerns that we've been trying to
address a specific of robbing positive
people that that is true you will
produce some emissions from the process
but with the carbon capture that's
available these days if you look at that
power generation plants for coal-fired
power generation it's much less produce
polluting than they ever were because of
carbon capture facilities and these
plants do healthy the the current and
you're sure that the March is set to
capture then mix up for
well basically what you're releasing
compared or something you've got I
suppose you've it's one of those things
you don't if you don't do anything with
it it's still going to be there there's
a lot of energy going into the
processing of that plastic in the first
place so you might as well do something
with it rather than burn natural gas
this is with my point on the last one
rather than take a new source of natural
gas the North Sea from Russia we can
actually burn this yes is another
question thank you there's another
question of the fronton Naja Kershaw Co
a big issue invest
I'd love to invest in it but I know what
I do because I think any of the profit
would make I would like to put back in
that she's going upstream and solving
the problem wide exists the first place
because I think although I think we you
have to do something like this actually
what we have to do we start changing how
we produce how we consume and the rest
of it and now if you look at the
convergence between environmental and
social you've only got to look at the
famine or water or whatever unless we
start to do that so I think as a short
term solution absolutely yes yes it was
a long term solution we really have to
do our energies into into manufacturing
and how we consume if we're gonna go and
essentially invest in this to put
ourselves out of business
yeah I I totally agree with you it's a
short-term interim probably 10-year plan
hopefully if you saw the figure the
first figure where the use of plastics
over the last 50 years has been
increasing your own urine-y we need to
do something with that so we reuse more
of that plastic I mean everyone it hope
those figures on mobile phones people in
the around the world have three and a
half mobile phones in their drawers
somewhere which is a lot of plastic and
a lot of rare earth metals that need to
be reused so so we start thinking about
how we tackle these problems the
problems we make things too complex to
to basically reverse engineer to
actually take back to fuel components
and they're a lot easy to process but
when we have this mix plastic waste I
think this at the moment
any alternative burning to do another
one or should we let go off the hook
thank you very much